given all of the data that we've
explored in the last video and that we
have over here the very high debt to gdp
burden that greece has and the very weak
economy it's already in a deep recession
it's especially apparent when you look
at its unemployment rate this is the
period october 2010 to march 2012
unemployment rate was already high in
2010 and it's just been going through
the roof it's already in the low 20
which is a huge number and even that is
understating how bad things are on the
ground in greece because the
unemployment is disproportionately
affecting the young so if you looked at
the unemployment rate for people in
their 20s it would be much much much
higher than even this already
unbelievably high unemployment rate and
we've already explored that the bond
markets are expressing that by asking
for higher and higher interest rates
from greece these are the long-term
interest rates in greece and so the
possible outcomes the possible outcomes
that we're talking about here so this is
greece
the possible outcomes for greece the
only way that they're able to stay in
the eurozone is if someone essentially
writes them a really really huge check
that essentially takes care of a good
bit of their debt so one option is is
that they get bailed out
they get bailed
out by the rest of europe and germany is
a major actor here because they are the
largest economy of europe but what with
the bailout people are saying hey look
if we're going to write you a big check
you've got to cut some of your excesses
you've got to cut some of your
mismanagement so the bailout packages
are all tied to some form
some form of austerity now we've already
talked about we've already talked about
why austerity is definitely not
politically popular in greece but why
it's also it might just be a scary thing
to do because you already have an ultra
weak economy you have already have
unemployment going through the roof what
happens if you get even more austere
from where you are now if you do a
drastic cut to government spending from
where you are now this could go to who
knows where to a large degree this rise
in unemployment is due to the last few
rounds of bailouts and austerity and so
that's why the greek people are getting
very suspect of this austerity but if
that doesn't happen and we've talked
about this in the last video if that
doesn't happen the only the only viable
option for greece is to go off the euro
so leave
leave the eurozone the eurozone is the
subset of european union countries that
use the euro as their currency and we
already talked about this would not be a
painless process they would leave the
eurozone they would maybe their new
currency would be the new greek drachma
drachma and with this it would probably
be hugely devalued relative to the euro
so you would have savings wiped out
maybe not fully wiped out but savings
devalued for greek savers and they know
that already and that's why because this
this outcome is looking more and more
likely people are there's essentially a
run on banks in greece right now people
are going withdrawing their euros so
that they can stuff it in their mattress
and so that it won't be converted into
devalued drachmas but that's having the
effect of of really weakening and
potentially breaking down the banking
system so you could have bank failures
bank you could have bank failures
and the whole strategy of of leaving the
euro zone leaving the euro and going to
the drachma would be to inflate away
your liabilities would be literally to
inflate away your debt obligations and
your entitlement obligations but that
inflation and this has definitely
happened in the past in countries in
this situation could very easily turn to
hyper hyperinflation
and so whether you look at austerity in
this reality where you get bailed out or
you look at this reality over here in
either situation the in the medium term
the economy can really fall apart it's
really not clear how how outside of
maybe an extra generous bailout how that
can be how that can be avoided and so in
that situation economy falls apart
economy falls apart
falls apart and when economy falls apart
in a big way
and you have major social and you have
major unemployment it's a scary thing it
can lead to social unrest we're not
talking about eight nine percent 10
unemployment like we have the united
states we're talking about 20 30 40
unemployment even higher in the folks
that are likely to be
unrestful socially which is the young
people and so this could lead to social
unrest
social unrest and even radicalization of
the you know when people get
when people start worrying about whether
they're going to get food on the table
and they don't have a job
they might start supporting people who
have more radical views so just that by
itself is a very very scary proposition
the history of europe tells us that even
if relatively small countries in europe
fall apart in this way it could have
repercussions in the rest of europe
that's how world war one and world war
ii got started and so just by that just
that reason alone is reason enough for
people for people to think very
seriously about bailing grease out and
that doesn't come without moral
consequences the counter argument is if
we bail them out if we bail them out
doesn't this reward doesn't this reward
mismanagement and overspending
mis-mismanagement
mismanagement and even a little bit of
shady accounting on their national on
their national economic statistics so
there's very good reason if you are a
german taxpayer that you're very
suspicious suspicious of these bailouts
why do we keep writing checks to the
greeks if they're not willing to take
some pain now the greek side of it is
look we've already taken them out of
pain we're already kind of on the brink
possibly crossed the brink
if you take us if you if you force even
more pain on us then we're going to be
in a really where our our society is at
the risk of falling apart so we're in
desperate situation this isn't a time to
kind of force us uh to kind of force a
moral point on us so that by itself is
reason why people are worried but then
there's even a bigger reason that greece
might not be the only it's only the
first maybe the worst of the situations
but if greece falls apart and especially
if the eurozone if i say the european
union or europe is not able to bail out
greece that's an implicit signal to the
rest of the world that europe is not
able to essentially bail out its
countries and so you see on this chart
right over here you see on this chart
right over here greece is not alone it's
definitely the worst but right behind it
you have portugal and it's debt you have
long term debt with interest rates it
looks like it's around in the 12 and 13
percent range portugal has a 93 percent
debt to gdp ratio it already has a very
high unemployment rate if greece is
allowed to leave the eurozone and does
not get bailed out investors are going
to start wondering well hey maybe
portugal is not going to get bailed out
that's going to make people expect more
interest from portugal in order to lend
them money and they need money in order
to continue operating in in in the way
that they're operating but every
increase in a percentage point right
over here is going to really eat into
portugal's gdp and kind of force them
down this debt spiral their debt as a
percent of gdp is almost 100 percent if
they have to pay an extra one percent on
that that one percent is going to eat
into their gdp and it's going to force
that portugal to become the economy to
slow down even more and make it even
more and more onerous and then they
would just kind of go in the same
direction as greece and once again
portugal's not alone italy has a very
high debt to gdp ireland very high debt
to gdp ratio spain has a very high
unemployment rate so the fear here
there's i guess there's two major fears
one is greece by itself can become a
point of instability in europe but the
second fear is if this thing isn't
solved that this could cause kind of
contagion or a chain reaction through
europe that people start getting freaked
out they start wanting to not lend to
these countries and that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy well they might
also have to leave the eurozone